.
* Treibende elektronische Musik *
No.
- No.
Mein Name ist Pascal Nufer.
Fünf Jahre lang berichtete ich
als Korrespondent aus China.
Es war eine spannende,
aber auch zermürbende Zeit,
geprägt von einem ständigen
Katz-und-Maus-Spiel mit den Behörden.
Jetzt will ich dem Land
eine zweite Chance geben.
Ich möchte die Menschen erleben,
nicht den mächtigen Staat.
Ich will mich mit China versöhnen.
Wow!
- Wow!
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Sie packen heute schon alles ein,
nicht?
Ja.
Ganz schön viel.
Fünf Jahre
war das unser Zuhause in Schanghai.
Hier habe ich
zusammen mit meiner Frau
und unseren beiden Kindern gewohnt.
Nach insgesamt 15 Jahren in Asien
ziehen wir nun zurück in die Schweiz.
Was uns dort erwartet,
steht noch in den Sternen.
Eine ungewisse Zukunft.
Was hilft in so einem Moment?
Für viele Asiaten
ist die Antwort auf diese Frage klar.
Immer wieder habe ich erlebt,
dass chinesische Bekannte,
jung oder alt,
Rat beim Wahrsager suchen.
Ich selbst
habe das bisher noch nie ausprobiert,
doch jetzt scheint mir
der perfekte Moment zu sein.
Und wer weiss,
vielleicht eröffnet sich mir dadurch
ja ein ganz neues China.
* Treibende elektronische Musik *
Im Korrespondentenbüro in Schanghai
beginne ich mit der Recherche,
zusammen mit meinem Regisseur Dave,
der aus der Schweiz angereist ist.
Aber du erhoffst dir
jetzt nicht wirklich
Erkenntnisse für dein Leben? Oder
denkst du, es könnte was bringen?
Also, wenn du mich jetzt so fragst:
Ich glaube ...
Ich glaube nicht daran.
Aber es kann tatsächlich sein,
und deswegen möchte ich mich auch
auf dieses Experiment einlassen,
dass da eine Person ist,
die irgendwelche Fragen anspricht,
an die ich vielleicht
nicht selbst gedacht habe
oder die ich unterdrücke oder so.
Wenn so viele Leute
in ähnlichen Situationen das machen,
kann es ja sein,
dass das beim einen oder anderen
auch wirklich was gebracht hat.
Doch wo anfangen mit der Suche?
Dank eines technischen Tricks haben
wir hier im Büro Zugriff auf Google.
Normalerweise
ist der Zugang in China gesperrt.
Deshalb finden wir auch nur Einträge
von westlichen Touristen.
Ja, das sieht aus wie in einem Film.
Ja, wie aus einem Comic.
Tarotlegerin Tiffany Pattinson
sticht sofort ins Auge.
Also, ich schreibe die jetzt mal an.
Ich kontaktiere sie per WeChat,
der chinesischen App für alles.
Tian, kannst du mal auf Baidu suchen?
Meine Assistentin
und Dolmetscherin Tian
wird in der
chinesischen Suchmaschine fündig.
Ein traditioneller Wahrsager,
gut bewertet, nicht weit von hier.
Ich glaube, es ist hier.
Ja.
Ich denke, du solltest vorausgehen
und Bescheid sagen,
dass unser Team gleich kommt.
Es wäre unhöflich, wenn wir
einfach so auftauchen würden.
Okay, bis gleich.
Also, ein bisschen nervös
bin ich jetzt doch.
Wenn er mir sagen würde, ich
oder eins meiner Kinder würde krank,
würde mich das schon beschäftigen,
obwohl ich ja eigentlich
nicht daran glaube.
Es gibt selbsterfüllende Prophe-
zeiungen oder wie man das nennt.
Wenn es mal ausgesprochen ist,
beschäftigt es einen dann doch.
Ah, sie kommt.
Anscheinend
braucht man einen Termin,
und bis Donnerstag gibt es keinen.
Er ist voll ausgebucht?
- Ja, voll ausgebucht.
Da bin ich noch mal davongekommen.
Doch zu früh gefreut.
Unser Fahrer Justin hat mitbekommen,
was wir suchen.
Er schlägt uns vor,
seinen persönlichen Feng-Shui-Meister
zu besuchen.
Justin, du kennst ihn persönlich?
Ja, ich kenne ihn seit fünf Jahren.
Unser Büro ist damals umgezogen
und er hat geholfen,
die Möbel zu platzieren.
Ah, yes, yes. Okay, okay.
Feng-Shui wird hier
nicht nur auf Möbel angewendet.
Hallo, Meister.
- Hallo, Meister.
* Der Meister spricht chinesisch. *
Okay.
- Über 5'000 Kontakte bei WeChat.
Ja.
Beim Feng-Shui
geht es um positive Energie.
Man leitet die Energie,
um sich damit aufzuladen.
Hier ist Süden. Da ist Südwesten.
Und dort ist Nordwesten.
Ich bin 1948 geboren. Deshalb
ist diese Position gut für mich.
Deshalb steht sein Bürostuhl dort.
- Yes, yes.
So sieht also ein Büro aus,
das komplett nach Feng-Shui-
Richtlinien eingerichtet wurde.
Leider ist es meist
der erste Eindruck,
der einem im Gedächtnis bleibt.
Also, wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass der Mann,
den ich als Menschen
eigentlich sehr sympathisch finde,
mein Haus
oder meine Wohnung einrichtet ...
Äh ... Ja ... Nein.
Wann ist er geboren?
Äh, ich weiss es.
Ja, hier ist es.
Um 21.10 Uhr.
All meine Daten
landen in einer Feng-Shui-App.
* Er spricht chinesisch. *
Haben Sie kein Problem damit,
dass Ihr Beruf sehr traditionell ist,
Sie aber
diese moderne Technik nutzen?
Ist das nicht ein Widerspruch?
Es ist einfach bequemer.
Die Interpretation
ist gleich wie früher.
Das ist die Kunst.
Im Feng-Shui gibt es fünf Elemente:
Erde, Wasser, Feuer, Luft und Metall.
Aus deren Verhältnis werden
meine acht Buchstaben errechnet -
mit überraschendem Ergebnis.
Ich sehe eine Pfirsichblume.
Du wirst viele Frauen haben.
Man kann Meister Weisser Kranich
zu Rate ziehen,
wenn man einen Namen fürs Kind sucht,
ein Datum für die Hochzeit
oder wie ich
eine generelle Beratung möchte.
Alles streng nach Preisliste.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Ich weiss immer noch nicht.
Ende des Jahres
brauche ich einen neuen Job.
Im Moment
arbeite ich hier als Korrespondent,
aber dieser Job
endet mit dieser Doku-Serie,
und ich weiss noch nicht,
was ich danach mache,
wenn ich zurück in der Schweiz bin.
Das Gesundheitswesen
wäre gut für dich,
denn Gesundheit
wird Metall zugeordnet.
Früher hatte er kein Metall,
aber jetzt schon.
Das Wirtschafts- und Finanzwesen,
Maschinenbau und Automobilbranche
wären auch nicht schlecht.
Ich würde nie in die Finanz-
oder die Automobilindustrie gehen.
Das liegt mir total fern.
Ich kann mir aber gut erklären,
wie er darauf gekommen ist.
Der berät sonst auch viele Ausländer,
Deutsche usw., in Schanghai.
Ein grosser Teil von denen
arbeitet eben
in der Finanz- oder Autoindustrie,
und ich glaube,
er hat einfach angenommen,
dass ich auch dazugehöre.
Guter Rat ist teuer. 200 Euro
wechseln per WeChat den Besitzer.
Okay.
- Hao, hao, hao, hao.
Nett war er ja,
doch ich will mehr wissen.
Ich habe mich mit Maja verabredet,
einer Sinologin aus Deutschland,
die seit über zehn Jahren hier lebt
und sich auskennt
mit chinesischer Spiritualität.
Hallo, gut. Ni hao, hallo.
Ich bin Maja. Ni hao.
Also, dieses ganze Feld
der Wahrsagerei gehört ja
in den Bereich der traditionellen
chinesischen Kultur und Religion.
Ich glaube, dass für uns als Westler
von vornherein
Verständnisbarrieren da sind,
weil sich die Religion an sich
im Westen und im Osten,
so muss man es wahrscheinlich sagen,
so wahnsinnig unterscheidet.
Maja will uns in die religiöse Welt
von China einführen.
Sie bringt uns zu einem taoistischen
und einem buddhistischen Tempel.
Chinesen sind häufig nicht
Anhänger einer bestimmten Religion.
Ein Sprichwort sagt:
"Ein Chinese ist Konfuzianer,
wenn es ihm gut geht,
Taoist, wenn es ihm schlecht geht,
und Buddhist im Angesicht des Todes."
Nur zehn Gehminuten entfernt
von meinem Büro
liegt der pompöse Jing'an-Tempel.
Wir als Christen
kommen uns ja komisch vor,
wenn wir einen Tempel
einer anderen Religion betreten
und uns dort vor der Götterstatue,
vor dem Götterbild verbeugen,
aber in ganz Asien wird das einfach
als Zeichen des Respekts gesehen.
Es gibt keine Gottesdienste.
Wenn du ein Anliegen hast,
kommst du her
und bringst deine Opfergabe,
sprich: Du entzündest den Weihrauch
oder spendest ein bisschen Geld.
Es ist mein erster Besuch.
Bisher habe ich diesen Tempel für
eine Touristenattraktion gehalten.
Das ist ... That's cool.
Ich scanne es mit WeChat?
- Ja, probier es mal.
Yes, yes, yes.
- Ah, yeah.
Analoge Räucherstäbchen,
digital bezahlt.
Genau, jetzt nimmst du es
zwischen beide Hände
und verbeugst dich dreimal
in jede Himmelsrichtung.
* Fluktuierende, mystische Musik *
Etwas seltsam fühlt es sich schon an.
Doch den Gedanken,
dass hier jeder willkommen ist,
finde ich durchaus sympathisch.
Das Zentrum des Tempels
bildet eine riesige Buddhastatue.
Der Buddhismus
ist vor über 2'000 Jahren
aus Indien nach China gekommen.
Rund 100 Mio. Anhänger
soll es hier geben.
Die urchinesische Religion
ist aber der Taoismus,
ein Vielgötterglaube.
Die meisten Anhänger hat jedoch
der sog. chinesische Volksglaube.
Er setzt sich zusammen
aus Buddhismus, Taoismus,
Konfuzianismus, dem Ahnenkult
und anderen traditionellen Bräuchen.
Am Eingang des Weissen Wolkentempels
begrüsst uns ein Wahrsager.
* Er spricht chinesisch. *
Was erklärt er uns?
Er sagt, das Problem ist,
du bist im Ausland geboren
und darum kann er für dich ...
Er kann dir kein Horoskop erstellen.
- Ach so.
Ich habe kurz überlegt,
ob es eine Ausrede ist.
Das muss man immer mit einberechnen.
Alle Tempel sind einer staatlichen
Religionsbehörde unterstellt.
Da ist es bei mir so,
dass automatisch,
wenn jemand kommt und sagt:
"Ja, es geht leider nicht,
der Herr ist aus dem Ausland",
es auch heissen könnte,
dass es diesem Wahrsager
im Moment vielleicht einfach
insgesamt zu heiss ist.
Religion
ist in China ein heikles Thema.
Nach 1966, zu Zeiten der
kommunistischen Kulturrevolution,
war sie komplett verboten.
Erst seit Ende der 70er-Jahre
herrscht wieder Religionsfreiheit -
eigentlich, denn seit 2013
ist Präsident Xi Jinping an der Macht
und unter ihm lautet
die oberste Parole: Sinisierung.
Jegliche Lehre
muss parteikonform sein.
* Wilde chinesische Musik *
Wir haben Glück und erleben
eine taoistische Zeremonie.
Privatpersonen
bestellen beim Tempel einen Termin,
dann verfeuern sie Papierautos,
Häuser und Spielgeld
in der Hoffnung auf Wohlstand.
Und im Taoismus
gibt's auch Wahrsagerei?
Die Wahrsagerei
ist im Taoismus angesiedelt.
Die ganzen verschiedenen Formen
der Wahrsagerei,
sei das eben die Astrologie,
sei das Feng-Shui.
Im Taoismus wie auch beim Feng-Shui
spielt das Qi, die Lebensenergie,
eine zentrale Rolle.
Nach taoistischer Vorstellung
ist sie der Ursprung der Welt.
Im Feng-Shui geht es darum,
eben diese Energie positiv zu lenken.
Siehst du? Das ist sie.
- (Tian) Das ist sie?
Ja, hier.
- Okay.
Wir haben uns von Maja verabschiedet,
und ich warte gespannt
auf die nächste Erfahrung.
Tarotlegerin Tiffany Pattinson,
die wir auf Google gefunden haben.
Tarot ist eigentlich
eine eher westliche Methode,
momentan aber sehr beliebt
bei jungen Chinesen.
Richten wir uns da drüben ein.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal,
dass du das hier machst?
Nein, das ist mein üblicher Ort.
- Ah, wirklich?
Wie hast du das gelernt?
Wie ich das gelernt habe?
Das ist eine lustige Geschichte.
Ich wurde in der Schule gehänselt
und niemand wollte mit mir sprechen.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine coole Art,
Freunde zu finden.
Dann traf ich
diese sehr mystische Frau.
Sie brachte mir die Grundlagen bei.
Seither ist es Erfahrung.
Wie ernst kann ich das nehmen,
was du mir gleich erzählst?
Ich denke, das hängt von dir ab.
Manche nehmen es sehr ernst.
Sie verlassen das Land
wegen meiner Weissagung.
Sie treffen Beziehungsentscheidungen
und heiraten aufgrund meiner Lesung.
Andere stellen einfach Fragen
und sehen es mehr als Spass.
Eine meiner grössten Fragen habe ich,
weil mein Leben
sich bald rapide ändert.
Ich war 15 Jahre hier in Asien,
fünf davon in China,
und jetzt ziehe ich
zurück in die Schweiz.
Was erwartet mich?
Wie soll ich mich darauf vorbereiten?
Okay.
* Eindringliche, sphärische Musik *
Okay, benutz deine linke Hand
und nimm eine Karte.
Dann gib sie mir.
Also, das repräsentiert dich.
Hier sehe ich zuerst,
was dich antreibt.
Du liebst es, zu reisen.
Es gibt drei Orte,
die dir vorschweben.
Du denkst, du hättest entschieden,
zurückzugehen,
du bist dir aber nicht sicher,
ob das tatsächlich schon
dein endgültiges Ziel sein soll.
Ja. Ich musste schmunzeln,
als sie das sagte.
Das ist natürlich das,
was mein Umfeld auch befürchtet, ja.
In meinem tiefen Innern
weiss ich schon,
dass mir die Schweiz vielleicht
schnell zu eng werden wird.
Die Sache ist die:
Ich will China im Guten verlassen.
Doch ich bin Journalist
und habe die ganzen Jahre
über viel Negatives berichtet.
Jetzt will ich meinen inneren Frieden
mit China finden.
Also, das bist du. Das ist China.
Es symbolisiert Augenmass,
das auf dem Kopf steht.
Das bedeutet bezogen auf China,
wenn wir es mal
als Person betrachten,
dass es sich
ungerecht behandelt fühlt.
Es fühlt sich, als wäre es
ungenügend beschrieben worden.
Da gibt es noch etwas zu tun.
Und diese beiden Karten erklären,
was das ist.
Die erste bedeutet,
du sollst Beziehungen pflegen,
Partnerschaften und Freundschaften.
Die zweite Karte
bedeutet reisen, viel reisen.
Zusammenfassend könnte man sagen,
geht es darum,
Beziehungen
mit Einheimischen aufzubauen.
Das könnte etwas sein,
worum du dich noch kümmern solltest.
Yeah.
- That's it.
Ja. Ja, ja.
Da hat sie auch wirklich
einen wunden Punkt getroffen.
Das ist etwas, was ich nach wie vor
wahnsinnig schwierig finde,
halt wirklich
Freundschaften zu schliessen
über den Kulturgraben hinaus.
Diese Brücke zu bauen.
Ich kann's mir nur so erklären,
dass ich zu wenig investiert habe.
Das ist aber wegen meines Jobs
echt schwierig,
weil ich einfach ganz oft
nicht da bin, oft absagen muss,
weil ich kurzfristig
irgendwo hinmuss.
Da hat sie absolut recht.
Also, das müsste eigentlich
möglich sein. Da müsste mehr sein.
Natürlich glaube ich nicht,
dass man mit Kartenlegen
oder Handlesen
in die Zukunft schauen kann.
Aber es war
ein überraschend gutes Gespräch.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(Dave) Also,
sie hat dich schon etwas verhext.
So sah es auf jeden Fall aus.
- Ja, vielleicht tatsächlich.
Einerseits ist es sicher Erfahrung
und das andere
ist auch einfach Charisma.
Es ist vielleicht tatsächlich
auch irgendwie ein Vibe
zwischen Mann und Frau -
diese weibliche Kraft,
die sie da nutzt,
spielt da garantiert auch mit.
* Stete, sphärische Musik *
Ich verlasse Schanghai
und reise dorthin,
wo chinesische Spiritualität
noch am authentischsten sein soll:
nach Taiwan -
oder wie es offiziell heisst:
in die Republik China.
Das Verhältnis zwischen Taiwan
und China ist kompliziert.
Bis 1949 waren Taiwan und China eins.
Dann rief Mao Zedong
die kommunistische Volksrepublik aus.
Seine Gegner
flohen auf die Insel Taiwan.
Bis heute betrachtet sich Taiwan
als unabhängig.
Während Mao auf dem Festland
die Religion unterdrückte,
durfte man in Taiwan
die Spiritualität stets leben.
Ein Drittel der rund
24 Mio. Taiwaner sind Taoisten,
und die Wahrsagerei
ist hier absolut alltäglich.
Von diesem Termin
verspreche ich mir einiges.
Wir haben eine Audienz
bei Star-Wahrsager Yu-wen Chen,
Vorstand des taiwanischen
Wahrsagerverbandes.
Ni hao.
- Ni hao, ni hao.
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Yu-Wen Chen berät die höchsten
Politiker und Stars des Landes,
und das schon in zweiter Generation.
Schau mal, das ist mein Vater.
- Das ist dein Vater?
Er zeigt all die berühmten Leute,
die zu seinem Vater gegangen sind.
Das ist, als er gestorben ist,
wer da quasi
das Begräbnis mitorganisiert hat.
Schon damals waren die höchsten
Leute der Regierung dabei.
Ich glaube, es geht ihm jetzt darum,
uns klarzumachen,
wie wichtig er ist.
Das ist vom Lions Club.
Dort bin ich Präsident.
Gibt noch viel Papier hier.
Meine jüngere Schwester hatte eine
hohe Stellung bei der Regierung.
Das bin ich
mit dem Polizeichef von Taipeh.
(Tian) Der oberste Chef?
- Ja, der oberste.
Es kommen also
viele wichtige Politiker zu Ihnen
und stellen Ihnen Fragen,
wichtige Fragen.
Heisst das, Sie haben hier
auch viel Einfluss auf die Politik?
Ich sage immer alles
ganz aufrichtig und gewissenhaft.
Aber Ihr Wort hat schon Gewicht?
Das ist Pai Bing-bing,
die berühmte Entertainerin.
Das ist eine grosse Verantwortung,
oder? Auch für das Land?
Genau.
Das ist ein Minister aus Malaysia.
Ich glaube, der beantwortet einfach
keine einzige Frage.
Deshalb können die Leute
auch zu ihm kommen
und er sagt einfach, was er will.
Nachdem uns wirklich jede Persön-
lichkeit präsentiert worden ist,
die diese heiligen Hallen
je beehrt hat,
kommen wir tatsächlich noch
zu meinem Anliegen.
Jemand hat mir gesagt, dass ich
nicht in der Schweiz bleiben werde.
Ich würde maximal zwei Jahre dort
bleiben und dann wieder wegziehen.
Was sagt er dazu?
Sieht er das auch so?
Werde ich ganz zurückgehen?
So wie du bist, wäre es seltsam,
wenn du kein Geld machen würdest.
Du wirst dorthin gehen,
wo der meiste Profit wartet.
Wo immer ich Geld machen kann,
werde ich hingehen?
Also, wenn ich in der Schweiz
kein Geld mache,
werde ich in ein anderes Land gehen.
Okay.
Tipps, die sich hauptsächlich
um den schnöden Mammon drehen,
und Ratschläge, die wohl jeder
einem Mittvierziger geben würde.
Dazu noch ein, zwei Treffer bei
der Beschreibung meines Charakters,
dann ist die exklusive Beratung
auch schon vorbei.
(Dave) Wie erklärst du dir es, dass
er in Taiwan einen so guten Ruf hat?
Ich glaube, das ist ...
Diese Frage
habe ich mir auch lange gestellt.
Er ist ja offensichtlich auch
der Präsident des Lions Clubs da.
Er ist ein sehr angesehener Mann
und offensichtlich
auch sehr gut vernetzt.
Ich glaube, das ist etwas,
was in der chinesischen Kultur
enorm wichtig ist.
Man nennt das Guanxi,
das Beziehungsnetz.
Und wenn man in diesem Beziehungsnetz
hoch oben ist,
stellt auch niemand mehr
etwas infrage. Das darf man nicht.
Das ist eine Hierarchiestufe,
die man erreicht hat.
Da geht man hin, weil man weiss,
dass der Chef auch da hingeht.
"Mein Freund geht auch da hin,
der muss gut sein."
* Langsame, ruhige Musik *
Mein Bedarf an Wahrsagern
ist fürs Erste gedeckt.
Mir steht der Sinn nach Wissenschaft.
Wir besuchen Professor Hei-yuan Chiu.
Er ist einer der berühmtesten
Soziologen des Landes
und Experte für Wahrsagerei.
Sie liegen immer falsch.
Sie bescheissen immer.
Ich habe darüber geschrieben.
Ich habe acht oder neun von ihnen
interviewt.
Was macht einen Wahrsager zu einem
guten oder schlechten Wahrsager?
Gibt es da Unterschiede?
Oder ist der eine einfach
ein besserer Betrüger?
Ja, der bessere Betrüger.
Warum glauben die Leute denn daran,
wenn es so offensichtlich ist?
Wahrsager oder Astrologen
sagen immer etwas Ambivalentes.
Das kann mal richtig sein
und mal falsch.
Wenn sie richtig liegen,
glaubt man es gerne.
Liegen sie falsch, sagt man:
"Vielleicht beim nächsten Mal."
Wenn man das Gesamte anschaut,
ist ihr Effekt
eher positiv als negativ,
sonst würde eine Gesellschaft
nicht erlauben, dass es sie gibt.
Sie haben negative
und positive Effekte.
Man kann sagen, dass die
Gesellschaft so stabil geworden ist,
weil die Leute an Astrologie, Wahr-
sager oder Volksreligion glauben.
Sie ist weniger chaotisch.
Sie erhalten die soziale Ordnung.
Andererseits denke ich,
dass das nicht gut ist,
weil die Leute
an falsches Wissen glauben.
Sie handeln nicht rational.
Enttäuscht? Ich bin nicht enttäuscht.
Ich meine, das ist ...
Wie gesagt, es gibt einen Grund,
dass das in meinem Leben
bis jetzt nicht stattgefunden hat,
weil ich eben auch genau das glaube,
was der Professor sagt.
Also, ich bin nach wie vor
interessiert, rauszufinden,
wie das hier funktioniert.
Ich fand auch spannend, zu hören,
dass die Hälfte aller Taiwaner
in ihrem Geburtsjahr
einmal zum Tempel geht,
um sich das Geburtssternzeichen
segnen zu lassen.
Also das ist hier offensichtlich
tief verankert.
Zwölf Tiersternzeichen
gibt es im chinesischen Horoskop.
Sie beziehen sich aber nicht
auf Monate, sondern auf Jahre.
Ich bin z.B.
im Jahr des Hasen geboren.
Jetzt ist das Jahr der Ratte,
doch alle zwölf Jahre
kommt der Hase an die Reihe.
Doch das Jahr,
in dem man geboren ist,
bringt einem kein Glück.
Im Gegenteil: Es birgt Risiken.
Dann müsste ich theoretisch
zum Tempel gehen
und die Götter milde stimmen.
Das ist der Affe.
- Yeah.
Die Ziege. Und wo ist meins?
Das Schöne an Taiwan
ist die Freundlichkeit,
selbst wenn man ohne Voranmeldung
mit laufender Kamera
einen taoistischen Tempel betritt.
Weiss er,
welche Eigenschaften der Hase hat?
Es steht da.
Höflich, ruhig, rein,
elegant, schlau -
und er hat das Potenzial
zu ewigem Leben.
Yeah.
- Du wirst nicht sterben.
Man hört immer nur,
was man gerne hört.- Genau.
So dachte ich zumindest
bis zur Befragung der Götter.
Was bedeutet der Umzug zurück
in die Schweiz für meine Familie?
Um das herauszufinden, muss ich
100 Stöckchen so lange fallen lassen,
bis eines herausragt.
Nimm diesen hier,
der ragt besonders raus.
* Der Mann spricht Mandarin. *
Die Nummer 10.
Okay, and now do the thing.
Jetzt muss ich die Götter fragen,
ob es auch wirklich
die richtige Nummer für mich ist.
Okay.
(Dave)
Woher weiss man, dass es okay ist?
It's heads and tails.
Einer fällt so, der andere so.
Dann ist es okay.
In der Schublade mit der Nummer 10
steht die Antwort auf meine Frage.
Um sie zu verstehen,
braucht man einen Fachmann
und ein Übersetzungsbuch.
Ich habe nach der Familie gefragt.
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Es geht doppelt runter.
Es sollte aber hochgehen.
Das Schlechteste.
* Er spricht Mandarin. *
Viel Pech, unvorhersehbares Pech.
Streit untereinander.
Du solltest meditieren.
Meditation.
Ich sollte meditieren?
Du solltest die Götter
um Schutz bitten.
Okay. Xiexie.
Also ich habe tatsächlich
mit meiner Frau telefoniert,
jetzt in den Tagen hier,
und habe ihr auch erzählt,
was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Überrascht war sie nicht,
denn natürlich kommt
eine schwierige Zeit auf uns zu.
Wir haben ein kompletten Neuanfang
in der Schweiz,
unsere Kinder
müssen neu eingeschult werden ...
Für alle ... Für uns alle ...
Wir wissen nicht recht,
wie es weitergeht.
Wir kommen an einen neuen Wohnort.
Das wird nicht einfach.
* Antreibende, elektronische Klänge *
Das Schöne an Asien ist,
dass das Schicksal
nichts Unumstössliches ist.
Es gibt immer Mittel und Wege,
es zu ändern.
Meditieren, die Götter milde stimmen
oder die Mazu-Statue besuchen.
Zurzeit wird sie
durch die Stadt Huatan getragen -
das grösste spirituelle Event
Taiwans.
Acht Tage
pilgern Tausende Heilsuchende
der Mazu-Statue hinterher.
Die Wassergöttin ist die wichtigste
taoistische Göttin Taiwans
und soll Glück bringen.
Am meisten Glück bringt es,
wenn du es schaffst,
unter die Statue zu kriechen
und dort zu beten.
Okay.
Ich weiss noch nicht, wie das geht.
Ich schmeisse mich unter die Statue.
Wow, das sieht toll aus.
Der Wen-de-Tempel
ist einer von rund 100 Tempeln,
an denen die Mazu auf ihrem
400 km langen Marsch Halt macht.
* Gleichförmige Klangschalenmusik *
Gläubige kommen nicht nur aus Taiwan.
Viele reisen extra
aus der Volksrepublik China an.
Für jeden mitgepilgerten Tempel
gibt es ein gelbes Band.
Für ihr Glück bringen die Pilger
Opfer aller Art dar.
* Er singt ein Gebet. *
Wann die Wassergöttin hier ankommt,
kann uns niemand genau sagen.
Vor dem Tempel
fährt dieser Lastwagen an uns vorbei.
Man sagt uns, darauf
würden die Mazu-Träger transportiert,
die hier
auf ihre nächste Schicht warten.
Schaut mal, die Füsse.
(Tian) Wow.
Warum machen Sie das?
Um die Mazu zu ehren.
Das bringt Glück.
Ah, okay.
Das ist die Mazu in Echtzeit.
Das ist die Ortsanzeige in Echtzeit.
Wir sind hier nördlich von ihr.
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Es dauert noch 3 Std.
- (Dave) Mhm.
Wir beschliessen,
der Statue entgegenzugehen.
All diese Opfergaben.
Ja.
Vor jedem Haus
bereiten sich die Menschen
auf die Mazu-Statue vor
und verschenken
selbst zubereitetes Essen.
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Ja, das ist sticky rice.
Manchmal ist er süss,
manchmal auch nicht.
* Pascal lacht. *
Ist okay.
- Ja.
Dann finden wir
die Wassergöttinnen-Warteschlange.
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Denkst du, es wird klappen?
Bekommt jeder eine Chance?
Ja, ich denke,
wenn man in der Schlange ist, schon.
Hinter uns treffen wir eine Familie,
die schon gestern
vergeblich gewartet hat.
Geht ihr alle zusammen?
Er geht mit ihr.
Er nimmt sie auf den Arm.
Schaut mal, sie sind bald da.
Oh.
- So, the fireworks ...
(Mann) Wo? Ah.
Das bedeutet, dort ist die Statue?
Was meint er denn?
Wie wahrscheinlich ist es,
dass man es schafft?
Also, da wir in der Kolonne sind,
sagt er,
ist die Chance 90 %,
dass wir es schaffen.
Aber gestern
haben sie irgendwann abgebrochen,
weil es zu lange gedauert hat
und sie dann weiter musste.
Und weil sie auch Angst hatten,
dass die Leute zu sehr drängeln.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonklänge *
Und dann kommt plötzlich
Bewegung in die Sache.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Sie lassen niemanden mehr drunter.
- Was ist denn das?
Nein.
Hello.
* Stimmengewirr *
Nein, das kann ja nicht ...
Es ist doch wohl
nicht schon zu Ende, oder?
Da kommt nichts mehr.
- Also haben wir es verpasst?
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
(Dave)
Nein, wir haben sie nicht verpasst.
Aber so wird es aussehen?
Jetzt werden wir etwas nervös.
(Frau)
Sie muss grösser sein als das.
* Stimmengewirr *
Seid vorsichtig, es kann
sehr eng und chaotisch werden.
Okay.
(Frau) Immer zu zweit.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ah, jetzt.
* Gongschlag *
Wow.
- Wow.
* Jubelrufe *
Wow!
- Wow!
Xiexie, Mazu. Xiexie, Mazu.
* Jubel *
Ja, es ist ein Riesenunterschied
zu den Wahrsagern und zu den Tempeln,
die wir in Schanghai angeschaut
haben, was da emotional abgeht.
Das hat mich jetzt
wirklich mitgenommen.
Mein Herz hat echt geklopft.
Sehen kann man
die Wassergöttin nicht,
doch irgendwie
schafft sie es tatsächlich,
alle glücklich zu machen.
* Wehmütige Saxofonmusik *
Einen Versuch
will ich noch unternehmen,
um auch einen Wahrsager zu finden,
der mich derart berührt.
Deshalb
reisen wir weiter nach Hongkong.
Die chinesische Sonderverwaltungszone
wurde 1997 von den Briten
an China zurückgegeben.
Spiritualität wird hier
auch heute noch
viel offener gelebt
als in der Volksrepublik.
In der Skyline tobt sogar
ein regelrechter Feng-Shui-Krieg.
Nur eines von vielen Beispielen
ist die Bank of China.
Als sie gebaut wurde,
liefen die Geschäfte der umliegenden
Banken schlagartig schlechter.
Der Grund war
die dreieckige Form der Fassade.
Das Gebäude zerschnitt
das gute Feng-Shui
und strahlte negative Energie
auf die umliegenden Häuser ab.
Die HSBC Bank wehrte sich.
Auf ihrem Dach wurden zwei Kräne
in Kanonenform installiert.
Sie schossen
die schlechte Energie zurück,
und prompt
liefen die Geschäfte wieder besser.
* Regelmässiges Klatschen *
In Hongkong ist Spirituelles
wirklich allgegenwärtig.
Man muss nur den Geräuschen folgen.
* Sie spricht kantonesisch. *
Sie sagt, es war nicht leicht,
deinen bösen Geist rauszuklopfen.
Du solltest also aufpassen.
- Oh, er war hartnäckig.
Sie wedelt dir das Pech raus.
Dieses Tuch
hilft gegen 100 Arten von Pech.
* Langsame, mystische Musik *
Oh, jetzt musst du
deinen Namen singen.
# Pascal.
Hongkong scheint mir tatsächlich
der perfekte Ort zu sein,
um einen überzeugenden Wahrsager
zu finden.
Mein Geheimtipp
praktiziert in einem Einkaufszentrum.
Aufs Ambiente kommt es ja nicht an.
In Hongkong spricht man Kantonesisch,
nicht Mandarin.
Deshalb begleitet mich hier
die Hongkongerin Chermaine.
* Klingeln eines Windspiels *
Hi.
- Hi.
Hello. Pascal.
Sprechen Sie Englisch?
- Natürlich.
Raimond Lo
scheint es genau zu nehmen.
Mein Geburtsdatum
rechnet er erst einmal um.
Zuerst konvertieren wir es
in den chinesischen Kalender.
In deinem Geburtsdatum gibt es
vier sehr wichtige Informationen.
Dein Jahr hat zwei Elemente,
dein Monat hat zwei Elemente,
dein Tag hat zwei Elemente
und deine Stunde hat zwei Elemente.
Diese acht Elemente
komponieren dein Schicksal.
Okay.
Mir gefällt,
dass er alles anschaulich erklärt.
Du bist ein Feuermann.
Es ist ein Yang-Feuer.
Du kennst doch Yin und Yang?
Yang-Feuer steht für die Sonne.
Deshalb sind Yang-Feuer
üblicherweise Personen,
die warm und enthusiastisch
wie die Sonne sind.
Doch es gibt eine Kehrseite.
Yang-Feuer-Menschen
haben ein hitziges Gemüt.
Was fehlt hier? Du hast Holz,
Feuer und Wasser. Metall fehlt.
Was ist Metall?
- Das ist Geld.
Oh, du weisst das schon?
Deshalb bist du kein Geschäftsmann.
Wenn du Geschäfte machen musst,
wird dir langweilig.
Wir können auch Beziehungen
zu anderen Menschen erkennen.
Z.B. sind deine Eltern Holz.
Holz unterstützt dein Feuer.
Sie haben sich viel
um dich gekümmert.
Als du jung warst, hattest du
deshalb keine schöne Zeit.
Du fühltest dich eingeengt
durch ihre Fürsorge.
Ich habe mich in der Kindheit
von meinen Eltern tatsächlich
manchmal eingeengt gefühlt.
Aber wenn ich heute zurückschaue,
da ich selbst
Vater von zwei Kindern bin,
finde ich, meine Eltern
haben das ganz gut gemacht.
Ich war wohl einfach auch ein Kind,
das sehr viel Freiheit suchte.
Sie haben sich jetzt sehr
auf die Vergangenheit konzentriert.
Sie schauen nicht so sehr
in die Zukunft.
Ist das zu hypothetisch?
Die Vergangenheit
ist natürlich wichtig.
Wir müssen bestätigen,
dass die Vergangenheit stimmt.
Dann können wir zur Zukunft kommen.
Beispielsweise im Jahr 2017,
da gab es viele Konflikte.
Und ab 2018
hattest du viel Glück im Beruf.
2018 war tatsächlich das beste Jahr
für mich als Journalist in China.
Ich fühlte mich am stärksten.
Das stimmt absolut.
Und 2017
hatte ich wirklich viel Mühe.
Und weil sich jetzt
die Elemente ändern,
gehst du zurück in den Westen.
Die Elemente
ändern sich zu Metall und Wasser.
Metall bedeutet auch Westen.
Wie kommt es eigentlich,
dass der chinesische Kalender
anscheinend mehr aussagt
als der westliche Kalender?
Oh, das ist ein grosses Mysterium.
Niemand weiss das.
Es heisst, dieser Kalender
wurde 2'600 v.Chr. erschaffen,
vom Gelben Kaiser.
Aber wie konnte er
so einen klugen Kalender erstellen?
Woher sollen wir das wissen?
Es könnten Aliens gewesen sein.
* Wehmütige Saxofonklänge *
Das war heute
z.T. schon entlarvend, ja.
Es war halt einfach überzeugend,
dass er wirklich Dinge
aus meiner Vergangenheit genannt hat,
relativ konkret an Jahre, an
Abschnitte in meinem Leben gebunden,
die jetzt tatsächlich gestimmt haben.
Zum ersten Mal
hatte ich echt das Gefühl:
"Okay,
da kann irgendwie was dran sein."
Beflügelt von dieser
wirklich besonderen Begegnung
plane ich für morgen
ein kleines Experiment.
Doch nicht ohne Vorbereitung.
* Sie spricht kantonesisch. *
Was möchtest du fragen?
Ich würde gerne wissen,
ob morgen ein guter Tag für mich ist,
um nach Macao ins Casino zu gehen.
* Sie spricht kantonesisch. *
Was hat er für ein Sternzeichen?
- Mein Tier ist der Hase.
Nummer 9 ist deine Glückszahl.
- Nummer 9.
Number 9? Okay.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
Es ist sehr asiatisch, sich von guter
Energie einfach treiben zu lassen.
Und gerade habe ich ein gutes Gefühl,
denn Macao ist nach unserer Freundin,
der Wassergöttin Mazu benannt.
* Treibende, klingelnde Melodie *
1 Std. dauert
die Überfahrt ins Spielparadies.
Wie Hongkong ist auch Macao eine
chinesische Sonderverwaltungszone.
Im Gegensatz zum Festland
ist hier Glücksspiel erlaubt.
Die Casinos machen deutlich mehr
Umsatz als diejenigen in Las Vegas.
Alles auf die Neun
setze ich im Grand Lisboa,
einem der ältesten Casinos
der schnell wachsenden Stadt.
Mein Budget beträgt
1'000 Hongkongdollar, rund 110 Euro,
gewechselt in zehn Spielchips.
Die Zwölf, nicht die Neun.
So läuft es acht Runden lang.
Doch dann habe ich eine Eingebung.
* Der Mann spricht kantonesisch. *
(Tian) Eins, sechs, vier und neun
sind deine Glückszahlen.
Okay.
Die letzten beiden Chips also auf
Eins und Vier sowie Sechs und Neun.
Die Pechzahl 13, da könnte man
fast abergläubisch werden.
Nichts.
* Pascal lacht. *
Es ist schon faszinierend,
was diese Wahrsagerei bewirkt.
Ich bin absolut kein Spieler,
und doch hätte ich
insgeheim darauf gehofft,
dass die Neun tatsächlich fällt.
Für mich
hat es sich definitiv gelohnt,
mich auf das Experiment Wahrsagerei
einzulassen.
Ich glaube immer noch nicht,
dass sie als Instrument
der Prophezeiung funktioniert,
doch als eine Art Gesprächstherapie
kann sie durchaus nützlich sein.
Mir zumindest wurden
einige wertvolle Hinweise gegeben,
die zwar vor mir lagen, die ich aber
nicht so klar sehen konnte.
Mehr Zeit für die Familie, meditieren
und die chinesische Kultur ohne jour-
nalistische Scheuklappen betrachten.
Freundschaften schliessen, bevor ich
das Land endgültig verlasse.
Genau damit fange ich jetzt an.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020